We have four quadrilaterals
drawn right over here.
And what I want
us to think about
is looking at this green
quadrilateral here.
I want you to pause
the video and think
about which of
these figures have
the same area as the
green quadrilateral?
And so pause the video
now and think about that.
So I'm assuming you
gave a shot at it.
Now let's think about it.
And the way I'm
going to think about
is to really rearrange parts
of this green quadrilateral
to make it look
more like maybe some
of these other quadrilaterals.
So for example, if
we were to if we
were to put a little
dotted line right over here
and a dotted line
right over here,
we see that our green
shape is actually made up,
you could imagine it being made
up of, a triangle, and then
a rectangle, and then
another triangle.
And what's interesting
about the two triangles
is that they represent
the exact same area.
They essentially
both represent, they
each represent half of this
rectangle right over here.
Let me do that in a color.
They represent half
of this entire thing
if I were to color it all in.
And if you have
trouble visualizing it,
imagine taking this top
part right over here
and then flipping it over.
It would look like this.
If you flip it over, this
line right over here,
it would look
something like this.
My best attempt to draw it.
So take that top section, it
would look something like that.
And then move it down right
over here to fit in here.
And then this plus this will
fill in this entire region
right over here.
So that original green trapezoid
that we were looking at,
if you take that top
part out, it essentially
has the exact same area
as a rectangle that
has a height of 4
and a length of 5.
So this right over here
has the exact same area
as our trapezoid.
And once again,
how did we do that?
Well, we just took
this top part,
flipped it over, and
relocated it down here.
And we said hey,
we could actually
construct a rectangle that way.
So essentially, and if
you want to know its area,
we could either just
count the squares here.
So we have, let me do
this in an easier to see.
So we have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15,
16, 17, 18, 19, 20 of these
unit squares right over here.
And we know that there's
an easier way to do that.
We could have just multiplied
the height times the width.
We could have just said,
look this thing is 1, 2, 3,
4 high and 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 wide.
So 4 times 5 is going to give
us 20 of these units squares.
So that's the area in terms of
unit squares, or square units,
of that original
green trapezoid.
Now let's see which one
of these match that.
So this pink one
right over here.
If you don't even
count this bottom part,
if you were to just separate
this top part right over here.
This top part is
4 high by 5 wide.
So just this top
part alone is 20.
And then it has this
extra right over here.
So the pink has a
larger area than
our original green trapezoid.
The blue rectangle is 3 by 5.
So it has an area
of 15 square units.
Now the red one is interesting.
It is 1, 2, 3, 4 high and 1,
2, 3, 4, 5 long or 5 wide.
4 times 5 is 20 squares,
and you can validate that.
And so the red rectangle
has the same area
as our original green trapezoid.